there's new political fallout in
congress from the assault on the capitol
and a rift in the republican party is
growing
republican lawmakers like marjorie
taylor greene are
at the center of it she is openly
feuding with her republican colleagues
and now some democrats
are taking aim at the controversial new
lawmaker and as nicole killian reports
the republican leadership
is trying to maintain gop unity
as infighting grows inside the gop house
minority leader kevin mccarthy went to
former president trump's mar-a-lago
resort
hoping to win his support for
republicans looking to take the house
in 2022 the meeting comes as democratic
lawmakers called to push
out one newly elected republican now
they're trying to expel me from congress
at a town hall in dallas georgia a
defiant marjorie taylor green
you know it's a witch hunt the georgia
congresswoman received a standing
ovation as she rejected calls for
expulsion
after endorsing violence against
democratic leaders on social media
why are you supporting red flag gun laws
that attack our second amendment rights
and video also surfaced from 2019 of
green confronting a survivor of the
parkland school shooting you have
nothing to say
congresswoman johanna haynes represents
newtown connecticut the site of the 2012
sandy hook
shooting in a letter she urged gop
leaders to remove green from the house
committee on education and labor
proclaiming that mass shooting was
staged the idea that we have
a sitting member of congress trafficking
in conspiracy theories
calling mass school shootings false
flags re-traumatizing families harassing
victims
of school-based shootings it's dangerous
with tensions and safety concerns
running high house speaker nancy pelosi
says
more funding may be needed for
congressional member security
the enemy is within the house of
representatives
security could get tighter here the
acting chief of capitol police wants
permanent fencing around the complex as
for the republican rift one of the
former president's
staunchest allies florida congressman
matt gates traveled to wyoming yesterday
asking voters to defeat their
congresswoman liz cheney cheney was one
of 10 house republicans who voted to
impeach
mr trump that fencing would definitely
change the look of washington d.c nicole
thank you very much